mattias in Nagpur way is on his morning
Patrol he is tracking footprints and
listening out for the roar of lions one
of them visited the Rangers camp the
night before our 5 minutes to 7:00
enough for several o'clock with them for
some time the first economy kanji Lake
National Park covers more than 5000
square kilometers that's six times the
size of Berlin although it is home to a
large number of animal species
the park is struggling financially the
vegetation is so thick in some areas
it's hard to actually see much wildlife
the pock is also remote there are no big
cities nearby so very few tourists come
to visit at their team meeting in the
afternoon
the Rangers discussed the Lions and the
park there were 15 2009 but only 29 two
years later the head of the park fears
the number is even lower today they are
among the few lions remaining in Nigeria
without the Lions which is one of the
biggest predators in the park some of
these or herbivores and other species
will definitely not be controlled so the
line pollution is very very critical
it's very very important that we
preserve and conserve this lions after
the meeting the team heads out to look
for Lions the Rangers are armed because
they are frequently clashes with illegal
grazes hunters and sometimes with minors
with their limited resources
the Rangers struggle to face these
threats we've had cases where we engage
in shoot out with each other there are
cases we have fatalities will call you
opportunities you know this kind of job
is suspected we have really lost my
proteges suppose we'll call it Park
Rangers in the primary summit
suddenly the group comes across cattle
in the middle of the National Park
the Rangers immediately search for the
owner of the cows but the herdsmen is
nowhere to be found
of course we are resting we're
persecuting maybe jail for some years
for months livestock can bring new
diseases into the park that represents a
serious threat to wildlife that is one
reason why it is crucial for the Rangers
to work together with the villages
nearby Matias naguieru a has come to
Comanche to tell the people why they
should help protect the park the animals
we have there are some places in the
world
yellow lion in Europe West Africa near
dinner
money but it is not easy to convince the
local chief and the villages many
struggle to make a living
everybody we have no issues with
conservation but we don't have enough
farmland never ate that guy we would
like them to make the park smaller so we
can have more land to family as in a
guru he heads back to the park he still
hopes to spot some lions they can't
before but none actually show their face
I'm disappointed because for the past
eight days or nineties we've done a
thorough survey of the place and not
already here deer are but we are we have
to identify the roaring is not
accessible for now it's not like clean
so that's what we are crossing the lines
dangerous to jaws go Indiana the next
morning at the park Museum in a guru a
tells his colleague about the patrol in
the night although he wasn't successful
this time and didn't see any lions
the Rangers keep on following their
mission as many people as possible
should be able to see the Lions not in a
museum but and the wild